one of the best of all time love this
man love everything about him and uh i
would say that even if he wasn't maybe
listening to this introduction he is the
great bob costas here on the rich eisen
show how are you doing bob
rich i just picked up the phone
you plan to introduce me first in some
fulsome and appropriately appreciative
fashion thank you very much
okay
all right sir uh i give you the floor on
yesterday's news that it was david ortiz
and only david ortiz that earned
enshrinement into cooperstown bob you
know there are distinctions to be made
and i think we all made these points
yesterday on the major league baseball
network during the marathon
coverage we had there are distinctions
even within those who are connected in
some sense to peds
in the case of david ortiz he shows up
on the 2003 survey testing a
the results were not supposed to be
connected to any individual they were
trying to find out if as a group the
level of use was high enough to
institute testing and penalties to go
along with it and the results should
have been destroyed once they had the
total
macro number the micro didn't matter
plus apparently there were at least 10
maybe more false positives within it or
there could have been positives from
things that you got that were not
illegal either by law or by uh what
baseball fail uh planned rather uh to
put on a list of banned substances and
that doesn't mean that that
automatically acquits david ortiz in
that circumstance but it creates enough
doubt plus no matter what people might
speculate about the bulk of his career
played out when there was testing and he
never tested positive so i think that
he's in a different category than
someone like a rod uh who was suspended
a couple of times who sued baseball etc
etc great a player as a rod was he put
him in a different category different
category than manny ramirez um
different category than bonds and
clemens whose careers predated testing
for the most part and when there was
testing somehow they evaded it uh toward
the ends of their careers but it's
pretty clear especially in bonds case uh
clemens was probably able to sustain and
maybe regain
a certain standing because of ped use
but bonds who was already one of the
greatest players of all time was
transformed from a genuinely great
player to a superhuman player who turned
baseball into a video game so
they're they're all kind of in different
categories and i think the voters parsed
david ortiz
differently and his popularity and his
pleasant personality probably didn't
hurt him they parsed that differently
than clemens um and bonds and kurt
schillings in an entirely different
category the only guy who in his last
year saw his vote total go down
and not by a little by a lot he says hey
i don't want to be on the ballot don't
vote for me and apparently a lot of
writers said okay if that's what you
want we'll comply
uh
kirch and but let me say this
as i've said forever rich all three of
the guys i just mentioned
bonds clement schilling if i had a vote
and as you know only writers do uh
regardless of what my misgivings might
have been
with regard to some aspect of their
candidacy i would have voted for all
three of those guys and it should be
said that a majority of voters did vote
for all three but the threshold is 75
so what about the idea bob of
just putting on their plaques that they
whatever their accomplishments however
you want to write it on their plaques
because that's the way it's done
um for for this museum because that you
know there's a word museum in the title
for a reason
that you you um you just put in the
steroid era and that's it that's the
that's the those words are are the if
you will asterisk that you can infer
from
from their plaque and that's how you
leave it and and don't leave it to the
writers to parse out who may have done
it who didn't do it who did it but never
got caught you know just that's it and
then and then if the if that pisses off
the enshriney even so be it but they're
in because you can't tell the story
without them certainly because there was
an era of baseball the steroid era
that's a fact
there's a number of thoughts that come
to mind as you pose this question rich
so i apologize for what might be go for
it um a long answer
it's not a short one you know i don't
it's it's not an easy question right
well howard bryant uh the esteemed
writer for espn biographer of hank aaron
uh chronicler of the steroid era wrote
one of the most
thoughtful books about it has an
upcoming biography of ricky henderson
long-time member of the writers
association he has not submitted a
ballot some people submit a blank ballot
he hasn't voted at all for the last five
years as a protest
about the fact that the hall of fame
provides no guidance which is part of
what you're alluding to here how do you
parse this even somebody who wants to
say
look uh i'm an absolutist about it i
don't care how good you were if you use
peds and i strongly believe you did for
even a portion of your career i'm not
going to vote for you on the other hand
we know
that there are guys who we can
reasonably assume did use peds who were
already
in the hall of fame and none of them
were as good on their natural merits as
barry bonds was
so so you have that you have that aspect
of it um
and i had several other thoughts and
then they drifted out of my mind while i
was making that point
so
you you you better book me several times
in the next week or so because i'm
completely incoherent no no but
i i totally you know hear you bob
because it is something that has many
different levels to it
and and you know with with the fact that
you're you're don't give guidance to the
voters
thus you have some like you mentioned
howard bryant saying i'm not voting at
all then you got six that don't
you know say i am voting but there's
nobody here on the piece of paper which
is absurd
it's absurd that you know that that you
can't say that anybody on that piece of
paper wasn't head and shoulders special
above somebody else
from their era and then you wind up
having this conversation
which is
kind of uh useless right when it all
comes down to it that's why
you know i hear like let's have a
special wing another room just for these
guys put them in the same room but just
the words in the steroid era appear on
the plaque
and i don't know i guess there's a
committee who decides those words go on
there as you know i don't just say
things i try to figure out what the
mechanics would be of doing that yeah
but maybe that's that's what you do yeah
there's a there's a committee at the
museum that says we're putting those
words on it and that's the end of that
yeah that makes sense and i'll address
that in a second i've now remembered the
right other point which is this you said
as many people say hey it's a museum
well yes it is and if you've been there
you know that pete rose
shoeless joe jackson barry bonds roger
clemons they are all prominently
represented in the museum part
for their achievements uh for the years
they represent as is segregation as is
labor strife the the history of the game
is told in cooperstown
as a museum but the gallery where the
plaques hang
is a separate question
but i agree with you
that they could they could have done it
with pete rose way back when you list
his achievements and at the bottom of
the plaque it says suspended for life as
an active participant in baseball 1989
for involvement with gambling some
version of that uh you let's say you're
talking about barry bonds put all the
achievements there one of the it starts
one of the greatest all-around players
in the history of baseball which is
beyond dispute and then something toward
the bottom
that says uh
accomplishments
discounted by some or diminished bis
for in the minds of some uh for
involvement in the steroid era something
like that some sort of anodyne thing
like that which directs people
especially in subsequent generations
some 12 year old kids walking through as
yet unborn and um and doesn't quite know
how to put it into the context well he's
standing right there you want it in
context there's a an mlb library there
there's a museum next door it's actually
in the same building but the next part
of the building that's one way that you
could handle that um i just think it's
not possible to have you you can keep
raphael palmero out regrettable as that
may be raphael palmeira was a very good
player who has hall of fame credentials
just based on the numbers but you can
tell the general history of baseball
without raphael palmeiro
as good as he was he's not in the elite
inner circle but barry bond sure as hell
is on his natural merits
so i you know i just don't think you can
look the other way you've got to make
some kind of common sense accommodation
to how great he was while at the same
time acknowledging that even though what
he did inflated his numbers it
diminished his standing no question
about that and and so what we're what
we're kind of knocking around here bob
bob costas here on the rich eisen show
is removing the argument from the level
of
should this player get into the hall of
fame at all
into
now now now it's an argument about
actual language on a plaque
and so
uh i would prefer it to be about
language than just about entry at all
so um how does something like this get
done does baseball once they're through
what hopefully isn't a nuclear spring
fig like get get knock heads together
figuratively and or how does it or is it
is it a baseball writer's decision like
how does this get streamlined you know
writers vote but they don't run the hall
of fame and people may assume but
incorrectly
that central baseball on park avenue
runs the hall of fame
the board of directors of the hall of
fame do
under the larger auspices of jane forbes
clark whose family has underwritten much
of the hall of fame and helped it
improve as a museum and a site for
tourists so they've done a great service
but there's kind of a central power
there and that little hamlet in upstate
new york which brings me to this
in 1991
and this is only tangentially related
but it's interesting in 1991
the board of directors of the hall of
fame
decided that they would put in this rule
anyone who is on the permanently
ineligible list is not eligible for the
hall of fame ballot
now that was clearly aimed at pete rose
and pete rose alone because then since
he last played in nineteen eighty six
then he was on the cusp of being
eligible for the ballot
so it's an ex post facto rule
didn't exist no clear thinking person
denies or doubts that based on the rules
that pete rose should have been banned
from baseball for life and then he
didn't make his case any better by lying
about it for a long time and then only
coming clean um when he wanted to sell a
book plus nobody would ever nominate him
for citizen of the year it's problematic
in other respects when you look at
pete's life in its totality but pete was
an undeniably great ballplayer who never
so far as the evidence indicates
consciously cheated the game in fact it
was the opposite of that he lived for
the game and he played all out at all
times so they put in this rule after the
fact
now think about that think of the people
the various miscreants for their off the
field activities and steroid users and
whatnot who at least are on the ballot
they get to be considered pete rose has
never been
considered
it just doesn't doesn't make any sense
now
everywhere you turn i said this
yesterday at the end of the the
broadcast on mlbn
pete rose is banned from baseball this
segment brought to you by draftkings
[Laughter]
despite the proliferation of gambling
legalized gambling which all the sports
leagues now not only tolerate they
encourage they actively encourage
there's still uh a prohibition on
gambling for anybody directly involved
in the game and that includes employees
of the major league baseball network
they're all subject to sanctions of
various kinds and if you bet on baseball
right now if mike trout bet on baseball
he's subject at least as according to
the written rule to the same penalty
that that was meted out to pete rose
okay
fine but still think about pete rose
who's now 81 years old and in the
present atmosphere gambling's being
encouraged
what harm would it do not to put him in
by acclamation but to put his name on
the ballot let him be considered the
same way that barry bonds and roger
clemens were considered yesterday and
have been considered for the last 10
years and will be considered again by
veterans committees
bob cost is here uh on the rich eisen
show okay so does this end the
conversation because
bonds and clemens have now uh lost their
eligibility to be voted on year in and
year out where where does it go from
here essentially
everybody is eventually remanded in a
sense to baseball's court of appeals
which are the various veterans
committees right but coincidentally the
modern era today's game i think they
call it it goes in cycles uh the today's
game era consideration comes up again
this december
so it's a 16-member committee
the composition of the committee's
change over time
it's not all former players it's writers
executives former players and managers
same standards smaller
uh electorate but you still have to get
75 percent you still need 12
out of the 16 votes so roger clements
and and barry bonds and kurt schilling
for that matter are right back in the
discussion before this year is over
before i let you go bob um it is the
two-year anniversary of the passing of
kobe bryant uh i would be remiss if i
didn't
ask you of um i guess
your favorite brian story or one that uh
leaps to mind um from when you were
uh at the mic and his ascendancy was
front and center
some some quick thoughts i heard the end
of his conversation with you as i was
waiting to come on you can't help but be
struck by how thoughtful he is
you know we often say well someone
expresses themselves well when they
simply put one word after another
effectively
but this was a guy expressing nuanced
thoughts
uh and a larger view of the world and
his place in it
very very impressive and he evolved as a
person over time including getting past
some missteps um
now on a personal level
here's what i remember when he broke
into the nba
right out of high school so he's still a
teenager i did one of the first
interviews with him
and it was striking how different he was
from most athletes you encounter
especially athletes of that age now
obviously he had a different kind of
upbringing he spent part of his life uh
young life in in italy uh upper middle
class maybe even better off than that
spoke multiple languages he just had a
larger sense of the world around him not
just basketball but the world itself and
you couldn't help but see that and then
i was lucky enough to be part of the nba
on nbc
um in the 90s and the in the early 2000s
and
playing along with shaq
had they been able to stay together
for a more extended period
a good portion of nba history i think
would have been different after all they
won the three uh championships in a row
2000 through 2002 and they seemed to be
in nearly uh unstoppable force and there
were good players around them but the
two of them were at the heart of it
and kobe i remember one game in the 2000
finals might have been game four
um
in indy
and shaq fouled out
the game went to overtime
and kobe who was already obviously
having uh an impact on the series but
when shaq fouled out you could almost
see it you can almost feel it it wasn't
like he didn't shrink from that moment
he grew in that moment this is what i'm
here for i got to be the guy right now
and at the end of regulation and in
overtime
that's when kobe bryant i think on a big
stage emerged as not just a star but a
great great inner circle hall of fame
type player right and and the true error
to jordan the true heir to michael
jordan we had many of the same traits no
question that michael had um and you saw
you know michael isn't often uh publicly
emotional and you saw at kobe's memorial
service how deep that connection was and
how much of himself he saw
in kobe uh reduced to tears as as he
spoke about him i don't know that anyone
will ever match or exceed jordan for a
variety of reasons because it isn't just
pure objective statistical basketball
excellence it's kind of the the period
of time in which it happened uh in the
nba and all the
the effects he had on the game and even
on pop culture beyond his basketball
excellence i don't know that anybody
will ever match that combination but in
terms of kind of their
their persona
their view of themselves their work
ethic
kobe was
was a little brother to michael
bob i greatly appreciate the time as
always uh look forward to having you
back on uh during the nfl scouting
combine i think i've got you booked for
three shows but wait i realize i'm
taking up your whole program
but i know that apart from the combine
you seek my nfl insights
i'm sure
i'm sure that you have talked about this
yes but i will reiterate a point i first
made on nbc five years ago okay i made
it again on hbo as this nfl season
started okay and how many examples of
this do they need
before they come to their census
the nfl's overtime rule in the playoffs
forget about the regular season there
are reasons to get things over quickly
that yes in the playoffs
this isn't just dumb
it's the dumbest rule in all of american
sports wow
it is almost air
it's obviously unfair in his face you
got a few minutes here you want me to
give you the full thing bob yes because
i have some thoughts on the subject too
this is therapeutic for me okay because
as you know i'm not as invested in the
nfl as you are yes sir i'm not following
it like i used to but anybody can get
engaged in postseason games i was
riveted by all four games this past
weekend and then it concludes with the
buffalo kansas city game here we have a
league gotta give context here you have
a league that will
examine six different angles and freeze
frames on a call in the second quarter
of an october game between the jets and
the jaguars
that will measure within a millimeter
for a first down
because after all we want to get it
right it's right then in the most
important games including the super bowl
let's flip a coin and have the outcome
so disproportionately influenced by
something as random as that on its face
it's completely unfair this rule we
score a touchdown games over score field
goal game continues is the rough
equivalent of saying that if the seventh
game of the world series goes to extra
innings and the visiting team scores on
a home run game over but if they scored
a sacrifice fly or a single the other
team gets to bat preposterous on its
face so it's unfair but also it
diminishes the drama
josh allen never touched the ball this
isn't some anomaly it happens all the
time it happened to aaron rodgers in
seattle and in arizona it happened to
mahomes himself in the afc championship
game against brady and the patriots it
happened to drew brees it's happened
over and over again matt ryan was the
mvp the year they went to the super bowl
the falcons blow the game they blow the
lead so i'm not absolving them of the
blame but if the flip had gone the other
way brady might never touch the ball
matt ryan never touched the ball how
does that enhance the excitement and the
drama and where's the audience going the
audience isn't going anywhere you got a
one o'clock regular season game that
goes to overtime you don't want it to
bleed over into the four o'clock games
that are nationally televised plus now
you're playing a 17-game season you
don't want to wear the players out but
now you're at the end the audience is
only building the drama is only building
how is it more dramatic to take the ball
out of josh allen's hands or aaron
rodgers or drew brees or patrick mahomes
or matt ryan or potentially tom brady
plus
in overtime under this rule rich one of
the key elements of the drama of
football is completely erased which is
clock management the race against time
and in that very game you saw it 13
seconds to go you're at the 25 yard line
but you do have two timeouts somehow you
get into fuel goal range that can never
be a consideration even if they played
for another two hours
the clock would have nothing to do with
it under these rules in overtime so it's
competitively unfair it's bad theater
and how many examples do they need
somebody says you know we need a stop
sign at this intersection because
potentially there could be a pile up
here ah now we don't need it now let's
have a half dozen pileups time after
time and you still don't put the stop
sign there this is idiocy
okay so if this was the nfl overtime
rule i would not have a chance to rebut
this would be over and we would just be
done you've made my case okay no but no
uh but here's the answer is what what do
you first of all you are assuming that
the that neither defense was gonna stop
either person you're assuming that and
the other games that could have gone to
overtime like say green bay san
francisco and also
the rams and the bucks might not have
had you're just assuming that whoever
loses the coin toss is going to lose the
game because their defenses are gas
that's not the circumstances for every
well hold on and then and then the other
aspect of it is what what happens if you
do
put into place what you're saying
is you now want to defer if you win the
coin toss you want to go second and thus
neither team is going to be as
aggressive as we would like
until sudden death finally does arrive
or do we continue to just let everybody
just within its own you get a possession
i get a possession and we keep doing
that how does it all play out from from
you from there you play a timed period
and they can have the competition
committee decide what that time should
be okay maybe for the purposes of drama
and not wearing the players out maybe
that's eight minutes
maybe it's ten minutes maybe it's a full
fifteen minute quarter right what
whatever it is the clock still comes
into play and all the normal dynamics of
a football game are in play it would be
more dramatic it would also be fair and
to your point yes the defense can stop
the team that wins the toss right and
elects to receive and how big an
advantage that is is proven by the fact
that if you played a hundred overtime
games under this rule not once would a
team ever defer they would always elect
to receive the ball but the defense
could stop them but that doesn't mean
that that's fair this kind of shrug your
shoulders hey just stop them well sure
but if you had the best defense in the
history of the league against the worst
offense in the history of the league
you still wouldn't say well no problem
we'll stop them
it's just it's an unfair advantage for
the team that gets the ball under these
rules well as you know i uh i am up
against in the radio business a hard out
so i only have enough time at left to
ask you do you feel better having gotten
this off your chest is this yes but then
i'll move on to something else that i'm
obsessing about like the comment i've
just deferred i've just deferred
obsession to the next bob that extra
inning idea isn't bad
oh shut up
hey don't start schooling with baseball
now we got enough problems here
shut up take care of yourself bob costas
take care thanks so much
ladies and gentlemen go maybe chris
brockman's crowning achievement the
seven plus years of this program saying
something that causes bob costa's tell
him shut up
please tell me that was clean enough to
use as a drop and that we didn't just
laugh too hard over it i think we got it
this yes
bob cost is telling brockman to just
shut up shut up oh shut up
says one of the most esteemed
broadcasters ever hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here